avec son âne gomez bonjour sandrine
bonjour damien et à la une évidemment de
la presse internationale leur très
attendu de l'opération barkan du mali me
allard on aurait pu croire que ce
retrait laisse re est un peu le pays un
peu plus vulnérables et bien il n'en est
rien si on regarde du côté de la presse
malienne la presse gouvernementale g
j'ai regardé ce matin figurez-vous
d'amiens j'ai regardé le journal l'essor
qui est titre regardez sur les femmes à
qui sont en position de force les femmes
à ce sont les forces armées maliennes
voyez cette image donc deux soldats le
journal qui écrit que l'opération manico
lancé le 1er janvier 2022 dans les zones
infectées par le terrorisme islamiste
donne des résultats tangibles sur le
terrain le journal qui écrit avec cette
grande restructuration de l'armée
l'équipement et la motivation des
troupes et bien l'étau se resserre peu à
peu autour des terroristes résiduelles
qui opèrent dans cette zone qui est à
peu près à 200 km de bamako le message
ici c'est donc regarder on est capable
de protéger la situation après
l'opération le départ de l'opération
française barkan qui s'est elle
transformée en opération fiasco et là
c'est un journal français métro qui
titre sur un lieu sur 20minutes bien oui
c'est bien de l'avoir monsieur vous à
las le donc 20 minutes donc qui titre ce
matin sur cette opération fiasco on nous
rappelle que le but de ces 5000 soldats
de barkan qui étaient déployées donc
dans ces cinq pays du sahel c'était bien
de contenir l'avènement d'un nouveau
foyer djihadistes en afrique de l'ouest
aujourd'hui est bien le journal constate
que c'est un échec on assiste à un
retour en masse nous dit-on des
djihadistes sur le territoire mais aussi
à l'apparition de nouveaux groupes
terroristes et trois raisons ici à
damien à ce fiasco tout d'abord cet
espace qui est aussi grand que l'union
européenne qui est très difficile à
quadriller désarmé africaine qui
finalement n'ont pas été formés
entraînés et équipés suffisamment pour
voilà pour pour contrer ces djihadistes
et puis aussi ces occidentaux qui
n'auraient pas réussi à remonter la
source du financement de ces groupes
terroristes alors un départ annoncé
qu'ils se fait un hall c'est sur fond de
tensions avec la junte au pouvoir mais
aussi de l'opposition grandissante des
populations c'est ce que rappelle ce
matin le guardian au mali mais aussi au
burkina faso au niger on a vu on a
assisté ces dernières semaines à des
manifestations anti françaises et puis
la presse s'intéresse aussi ce matin ce
nouveau scandale qui frappe encore la
famille royale en angleterre alors avant
cela j'ai je voudrais juste revenir
damian ce sursaut mais pardon entre
l'union européenne et l'union africaine
prévue à bruxelles lors qu'ils sont
venus à bruxelles et bien on va regarder
du côté de la presse africaine le
journal burkinabè aujourd'hui au faso il
titre assure ce dîner qui a eu lieu hier
soir en forme de mini sommet entre
emmanuel macron et ses chefs d'état
africains à l'elysée un dîner préambule
nous dit-on avant l'activation à du
départ de barkan et de la force takouba
la force européenne au mali le journal
qui précise dans son édito qu'il s'agit
ici de multilatéraliser je vais y
arriver un divorce à bruxelles la france
nous veut partir mais avec le label
européen et ça tombe bien du journal
puisque emmanuel macron et président du
conseil de l'union européenne alors ici
on met le doigt sur les conséquences de
ce départ quid du vide laissé par barkan
il faut partir sans désaxé la lutte
contre le terrorisme au sahel sent
désarçonnée la minus ma la sécurisation
du sel doit être un impératif
catégorique
alors vu de france on va regarder la une
du figaro qui qui titre sur la france
qui tourne la page de l'opération barkan
le journal qui rappelle ici dans son
édito qu'il s'agit de la plus longue
opération extérieure française depuis la
guerre d'algérie est ici philippe gelie
nous met en garde le mali sera bientôt
une partie du problème il pourrait
devenir un sanctuaire pour les groupes
affiliés à daher et al-qaïda et ce jour
là à qui en appellera bamako s'interroge
le quotidien et puis la presse française
aussi à la une elle a choisi ce matin de
donner la parole à ces familles de
soldats tombés au mal ils sont au nombre
de 48 des paroles des parents qui
restent inconsolables comme ici le père
d'alexandre qui veut croire que son fils
n'est pas morte pour rien selon lui 1 je
cite on ne peut rien reprocher à l'armée
française elle a fait son travail
correctement sans se comporter comme une
envahisseuses
elle a neutralisé beaucoup de jr east a
mené amener la stabilité au sahel en
tout cas c'est ce qui veut croire voilà
ce qu'on pouvait dire sur le sahel j'ai
voulu aller trop vite nouveau scandale
donc au sein de la couronne britannique
oui figurez vous qu après le prince
andrew bat désormais c'est le prince
charles qui est dans la tourmente sous
le feu des projecteurs au royaume uni
c'était là une de quasiment toute la
presse britannique ce matin le daily
express qui titre regarder sur la reine
qui fait face à une nouvelle angoisse la
fondation du prince charles en effet
visé par une enquête un ancien valet de
charles est bien est soupçonné d'avoir
aidé un homme d'affaires saoudien
obtenir une décoration alors ce serait
en échange de dons très généreux contre
donc des titres honorifiques voir un
coup de pouce pour une naturalisation
donc voilà une affaire qui aggrave
encore vous allez le voir donc cette
crise de au sein de la famille royale
nous dit le times à andrew on le sait
lui est accusé d'avoir participé à un
réseau de trafic sexuel du milliardaire
du défunt milliardaire jeffry obstine et
puis cette affaire a regardé encore elle
est qualifiée de très explosif à la une
du gratuit métro cette fois ci bien le
métro qui titre même sur le jubilé
plutonium atomique on se souvient qu'il
ya pas très longtemps la reine a fêté
son jubilé de platine un règne de 70 ans
et puis on retiendra aussi la victoire
française éclatante de clément l'ol aux
jo de pékin rires oui alors c'est
l'équipe a bien sûr un qui fait kid qui
voilà qui met à la une ce portrait ce
portrait de clément noël avec ce titre
la magie de noël facile voilà c'est
assez facile voilà en tous les cas ça
fait plaisir
clément noël donc qui a gagné hier
la médaille d'or en slalom à qui donnent
ainsi sa quatrième médaille d'or à la
france le journal un qui revient
notamment sur ce surdoué au calme
olympien qui très jeune on la prend ici
a fait des sacrifices pour pour le ski
voilà ça plait merci beaucoup sandrine
et